Hello, Marco. Good morning.
Good morning, Ira. How are you?
I'm doing good. How about you? How's your day?
It's going well so far. What about yours?
It's going well, perfectly fine. I'm pretty excited for today.
Yeah, how come? Is there something going on?
Yeah, first it's salary day.
It is what is Saturday, you said?
No, a salary day.
Oh, salary day. Okay, gotcha.
Yeah, so we're kind of excited. I'm hoping to log off soon so I can buy my favorite dessert and watch a movie before sleeping. Yeah.
I.
No.
Nice. What is your favorite? What is your favorite dessert?
Ah, that would be avocado ice cream.
Avocado ice cream. Interesting. I've not had avocado ice cream. I mean, I ate plenty and I eat plenty of avocados, but I never had avocado ice cream.
How about you?
So, it's kind of weird because...
The.
It's not that I don't like sweets, but I just don't eat them that much. I like more salty food. So like, for instance, like if you give me a choice between, I just can make something up, between ice cream or French fries, I will eat the French fries.
Mhm.
every single time over the ice cream. So in terms of desserts, kind of what I like is things that there are no overly sweet.
So if they're not overly sweet, I like them. So I would guess like more of a simple cake without like creams and, you know, things like that. And if they're warm. So like if you give me a brownie and it's warm, I would love that. That is something that I would like.
Ohh.
I just, you know, ultimately I not really like I can go where everybody is ordering desserts and I wouldn't order a dessert and I don't feel like I'm missing out.
Yeah, you're not a sweet tooth guy, yeah.
Yeah, no, I, you know what I do love quite a bit? Popcorn.
Popcorn.
Yes.
What I'm thinking is that your health conscious, that's why.
Well, you know, my belly disagrees with that.
Yeah.
No.
Yeah, because we see it a lot.
Yeah.
That is true. I mean, I do see quite a bit. I mean, I try to stay active as much as I can, but I mean, it's still, it's just not the same, you know what I mean?
Mhm.
Yes, we ate.
Yeah.
I heard that we should, like, in our age, we should take like 10,000 steps A day. Are you hitting that?
The.
And yeah, I'm pretty sure, so I don't, so I used to have a tracking watch before, and I'll tell you, it was maybe the worst thing that I did.
Because, so this is, I guess, you get to know me a little more on this. So I am, with certain things, not with everything, but with certain things, I get an obsessive personality of certain things. So for instance, like the...
Yeah.
steps, like recording the steps, that became an obsession, right? So if I walked, right, you know, let's say from here to the corner and back, if I was pushing a cart as an example.
Since the watch didn't record those steps, then I didn't walk.
Ha.
So that's how that's how my head will get into that stage. So whenever I was out or I was doing something, like if I was out of the supermarket, I will push the cart with one hand and I will make sure I will be moving the other one with, you know, where I had the, you know, like the watch.
That kind, ohh.
tracking the steps. So then this thing die. And at first I was like freaking out. And then I was like, you know what? I'm not going to get one. And that really was like the best thing because that allowed me to break that chain of like, you know, that I was.
you know, so obsessed with it. So what I do do is I make sure that I do.
two to three walks a day of like 30 minutes or more. And in my head, that equates to 10,000 steps because I kind of remember how long it used to take me to get to like the 10,000 steps before. So I may be off a little bit here and there once in a while, but...
Honestly, at that point, whether I got, let's say, 9,200 or I got 15,000, it doesn't really matter.
Yeah, it's weird that when your watch, it's not tracking it correctly, so that's where the frustration comes in on your part, right?
Yeah.
Right.
So I have this thing, the Apple Watch. It's tracking everything. It's good. Was that Apple Watch before?
And, and, and that.
Right.
No, it was not an Apple Watch, it was a Garmin watch. So, like, it did track very similar things, like, you know, it would track my sleep, it would track, you know, my blood pressure, you know, everything, right? Heart rate, all this stuff. And...
Ohh, that's expensive, too.
Mhm.
I'm not saying it wasn't useful because there was usefulness to it, but it was ultimately, without me realizing it, it was exploiting my mental health because, you know, again, for me,
Yeah.
Your mental health.
It's not doing its thing.
It is just providing more anxiety than not. I mean, I'll tell you this story and you're going to laugh at me. But there was one time, it was like nearly 10 o'clock at night. And I was like, oh, I need to go to bed. It's like, because I go to bed earlier than that. And I was like, I need to go to bed. It's too late.
And then I realized I was like maybe 9,600 steps. So I walked in my house like until I hit 400 steps so I could get to 10,000 and I could go to bed.
Oh my god, you won't be able to sleep if you won't heat that. That kind of anxiety.
So...
Yes, I wouldn't sleep well, yes.
Yeah, I wouldn't recommend. I wouldn't recommend you buying another one, Marco.
No, I and I haven't, so I it broke maybe.
seven months ago, and it really has been very, very liberating, you know, since that time, because then I'm like, I don't have to think about it anymore. And it was just like, it was created more of an issue for me than helping me. So, but I stay active. I, you know, I do exercise.
Yeah.
Leon.
You.
to whatever it is, even if it's walks every day. I do that, you know, it's part of, you know, what I am. It's just like, for instance, last night I went out with a friend of mine that I haven't seen for many years. You know, we went to, we used to go to college together and then, you know, we actually coincided in
Two jobs after that, and then you know we kind of from there we had not really coincided again, and we kind of, you know, kind of kept in touch but not really hung out, so yesterday we we decided to go out and you know it was nice seeing him, but it had been, you know, at least maybe like...
15 years or so since I had actually seen him last. And so we went out and I was like, well, yeah, I'm going to have a beer with you. I mean, of course I'm going to have a beer with you. And yeah, I mean, whatever. So, you know, I enjoyed the moment. I understood that that potentially, you know, having the beer or whatever was not the healthiest of choices, but at the same time, it's like, you got to live life, you know what
Yeah.
I mean.
Yeah, YOLO. You only live once, right?
Yeah.
You can't be living with this whole thing. It's like, oh, I'm gonna, I have to be perfect every time.
Of course, you have to give yourself a break, you know. It's nice to do some bad things at times.
Right.
Yeah, anyways, it's nice catching off with you. It's nice to get to know you more deeply. All right, thanks for that, Marco. I appreciate you. Shall we proceed with our meeting? Okay. Perfect. Let me just share here my deck.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
It's just a quick document that I have here. Let me know once it's available on your screen.
Ohh.
Not yet.
There he comes.
Okay, perfect. Once again, thank you for joining our weekly service call. The review would be from last week. That's April 20 to 24th. And it's already our week number 7. Agenda items are all the same. Check in. This is for you, Marco. How are things at this moment with you and Jane?
Mhm.
They're going well. We asked, maybe Jane may have given you an FYI. She was having problems yesterday morning with ConnectWise. So I ended up spending time with her, trying to fix it.
We got it resolved. The resolution made no sense whatsoever, but at the end of the day, it's working for her. But we spend, I mean, I know that most likely she spent a little more time trying to troubleshoot on her end first, but then.
Yeah.
And I mean, I know that she had put, you know, like a message for like kind of like help with other people on the team, but nobody else really has the access to do that. And I didn't had a chance to see that yet. And once I saw it, which it was maybe like within maybe 10 to 15 minutes of her sending that message.
Then I reach out to her and I started working with her until we resolve it. So, you know, I think, you know, she may have been...
let's say call it offline maybe for like half hour, maybe 45 minutes at most, that she couldn't really do the work that she was trying to do. But then, you know, we got her finally working. Again, nothing on her end that she did anything wrong. What transpired, we don't even know. And I had someone else on the call with me
out here from Tab and we couldn't really understand what was happening because we had seen the error that she had experienced, but usually just closing ConnectWise and reopening it kind of fixes it, but it was not doing it for her.
Yeah, it's kind of weird, right? Her connect with Spanish is really...
I don't know if it's like it's broken for some time. We had a lot of issues in the past, right? That it's loading, it's stuck somewhere, it's not working. I have that checked. I'm not sure what's really happening with her computer, with her laptop.
Yeah.
I'm thinking that it's the app itself. I'll have a quick connect with her after this, but then what else have you observed? Do you have any?
So.
So, I mean, just looking quickly in some metrics, I mean, again, and I'm not holding her accountable to this metrics just yet, of course, but, you know, she did open. So I did it two ways. I did it just kind of like, you know, from her start, which, you know, I know that she wouldn't be creating tickets at that time. She only will create tickets.
Tickets, you know, pretty much once she started being shadowed, so, but since that time she has created eighty-one tickets, so that tells me that during that time she has worked, you know, not just...
calls about emails and stuff like that. So that is a good number in terms of, you know, where we're supposed to be. Like if we really even think about that she just really started.
You know, being the one taking the calls.
And being shadow was maybe the beginning of April. And then I think, you know, officially she went independent on the 20th, but I think it was like maybe the beginning of April that she was, you know, where we reversed roles and then she was, you know, the one taking the calls and.
you know, with another CSR shadowing her, she's pretty right on par with everybody else in terms of like those metrics, right? So in that sense, I'm good. So she's right there. I mean, like for instance, just as an example, in terms of number of tickets created.
The one person that didn't have any real involvement in Jane's training, he had, he had for April 89 tickets, you know, Marie was at 81.
So I mean, it's very, very close, you know what I mean? So we're not talking here that that is, you know, a major discrepancy or anything like that. So she's falling right in line in there. And then in terms of other, just overall, the number of tickets that she has worked.
Kam.
you know, whether it is because she opened them or she's the one that ended up taking the ticket and moving it forward. And she has about 141 tickets that she's working on right now. Now.
With that said,
Some of those, of course, are closed now. Other ones are not, but that's kind of where we are with her. So I mean, she's fallen right in line in terms of, you know, what you expect to see someone on their first, you know, pretty much 90 days.
Perfect. I think that's a good number because she just started working independently, I guess, second week of April, right?
Mhm.
So, 81, that's the number of inbound calls, you say?
So is Das tickets that she created, so that could be either from calls or it could be from emails or things like that.
Bye.
Okay, and that's a good number, what I'm hearing, right?
Yes, it is.
Okay, and the target that we have settled before, that's 250?
So, for the calls coming into the queue, however, you know, now every call.
will become necessarily a ticket because you know sometimes people call they and they choose the service and it's just to maybe just ask a question. Oh, can you give me an update on this ticket that it already says? So you don't create a new ticket at that point, you know what I mean?
So there is that or there is like people calling about, sometimes they just call out something else entirely. And I mean, it's like, okay, yeah, no, you know, that's, you know, we don't deal with that. Or I think she was, if I remember right, she reached out because I think there was a call.
with someone that that was not a client and then wanted like, you know, some level of like potential support. And I just told Jane, it's like, this is what we do. And she's like, oh, yeah, it makes sense. So, so overall, I think the metrics.
Right now, they look like we are going on par to what we want. You know, like I said, the number of calls.
for right now, not important at all, is more like, you know, that we're seeing a progression. Of course, the other thing that is happening, which is kind of funny.
When she started.
When we looked at our schedule, our schedule was pretty packed for like at least two weeks. So we were booking into a third week.
But right now, the schedule is pretty light. So we have had a, you know, less of that demand. So when I see things like that, I also adjust the numbers because I can, you know, say, well, you know, this is proper. You know, I go based on averages, but sometimes it's like if the demand is so low, well, you know,
Yeah.
There's nothing that you can do to receive more calls, right?
Yes, of course.
Okay, great. It's good to hear that she's helping out the team a lot. And just like your example yesterday, if you're facing any problems with her computer or with her application, you can always reach out to me as well so I can look it here on my end physically.
The.
maybe we can have our local IT check it. And also for her performance, if we can do something differently to improve it, what would you suggest?
Yeah, yeah. So I mean, right now, I don't think we need to do any changes. I think she's doing well. Yeah, you know, she's going to become more and more familiar with things as she's going along. You know, most likely, you know, she's a little slower than, you know, she will be.
It.
you know, three months from now, but that is suspected.
Okay, cool. But then if anything that needs any changes, especially with the number of tickets that she can work on during the times that there are less tickets, feel free to let me know as well so I can cascade it to her. But then, yeah, that
It's all on my end, and what I have observed as well last week, I can see that she's also she started doing triage.
Mhm.
I'm just curious, can she close tickets if she can? Like if it's just a simple password reset, can she do it and close the ticket?
If she...
Yes, absolutely.
Okay, gotcha. So I probably have to tell him.
And there is a process for that, but yeah, if it's just a simple password reset, we have that documented, and she should be able to, you know, follow that and close it if it works for the client. So there are certain things like that that are very basic. Other ones is like...
releasing emails from the spam filtering service, you know, those are things that, you know, she can do, she can work on assuming that their clients that she has the access to do that.
Mm.
She can work on.
Yeah.
Plus, she can work on and close the ticket, right?
Right. So I mean, there are clients right now, of course, like the ITAR clients that she don't have access to that. But I mean, the process that we put in place because of that is working well. So in a sense, she creates a ticket under a, we have a generic.
Okay, cool. That's great.
Client that I created in ConnectWise called CMMC client, and that's where she puts those tickets in there. Like, if somebody calls, she lets the team know, and you know the ticket gets in there, and then somebody from our team grabs that ticket and and puts it to the right company, you know, and and and and assigns it to the.
the right board. So, you know, so far things are working okay. She's following along. You know, you know, the understood little mistakes here and there that happens when you're new and but nothing that I will say that there is a an issue or problem or anything like that.
Yeah, of course.
Yeah.
Okay, that's great to hear. Yes, especially if she's new, so it's normal for her to adjust to the environment that you have, but a good thing that she is reaching out to you directly, right?
Yeah, absolutely. Now, I do have a question for you because, you know, I think I saw it yesterday and I couldn't remember if it was like the previous week or, you know, or when, but, you know, she, she, she excused herself for like a little bit because she had a huddle with
Okay.
Sure.
and you know, the ITBD huddle. So how often are these huddles and how long do they last? So I'm aware, because I didn't know anything until she started messaging the teams like, oh, you know, disconnecting for a little bit and you know, huddle with ITBD. I was like, okay, I mean, I understand because we have huddles, so I understand the reason of having a huddle. I'm only just more like, okay, so.
How often are these huddles?
Yeah.
I think it was yesterday. I'm actually doing a daily pulse check-in with the rest of my team. That's only for 15 minutes. I usually do it by end of my shift, like around 4.30 to 4.45 and maximum 15 minutes. I also...
Ask them to add it to their manage. Is that OK with you?
That's okay. I mean, I mean, I'm not going to tell you now, because then you wouldn't be able to manage her properly. All I just wanted to make sure is that, you know, I'm like, okay, if there are the huddles, how often are they? And, you know,
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm doing it every day, five times in a week. Is that okay?
Okay, so if you're doing it every day, she does not have it listed at least for this week for every day. She had it listed for yesterday, but no, no.
Every day, now.
For other day, yeah. That's on me because I haven't done it. One day I was out, Tuesday I was doing something, so I started yesterday.
Gotcha. So my only thing that I will say is that if she is on the phone with a client,
Yeah.
she's not really supposed to try to like hurry up the call, hang it up so she can attend her huddle. So I would say, you know, ultimately she needs to make sure that the client is service, you know, and also if for whatever reason.
Yes, of course.
It usually won't happen this late in the day. But if for whatever reason, if it was like call after call after call, you know, she should be smart enough to say, you know, I can't leave the team hanging right now.
Yeah, yeah, of course. Whenever I see them busy or engaged on a call, they're not required to attend. I'm just doing it every day, so we have, we're keeping the team dynamics, you know. We have the policies and the recent updates cascaded to them properly.
Yep.
But then, if they can't attend, especially Jane, if she's in a call or something, I can excuse her.
Yeah, yeah. And so, like I said, I have no problem. The time seems to be right, which is, you know, at a time that usually is not that busy, so it should be okay. We just have to be mindful, and she has to be mindful of this, not just the number of phone calls, but just potentially the number of tickets that came in through email that they are on the board, that they may be on process.
So we need to make sure that we are on top of that before we make the decision to like fully disconnect to go to the huddle.
The hurdle, yeah, of course. That's why I also scheduled it like 15 minutes or 30 minutes before the end of shift, because we don't have a lot of tickets that time, right? Because it's actually the end of the day. But then, of course, I will assure you that I won't
bother her if she's on a call or if she's doing or watching the ticket board. That's it. Okay. Any other questions on that one? All good.
Okay, perfect. For a few highlights we have here, so as we mentioned, she's actually doing the triage management, the dispatch handling, and I can see that in seven weeks, she was able to grasp your environment plus the workflow.
that top computers are following though, so I'm good with that. Plus the minor application issues, yeah, I can help you with that. Just let me know. And then for the action tracker, this is the PTO, so we
completed this one. I already approved that. And I asked her to check because you added the time entry for her PTOs, right? And I also cascated to her about two to three people on the same day PTO. That's what she should watch out.
Plus, she needs to add it to her ConnectWise Manager. So you can see it, or the rest of the team have visibility to that. For performance analysis, actually, we did had a lot of conversation, a good conversation on that one, so we can skip.
This one, this is just the IT by design services. I'm aware, or I'm sure that you're already aware of this, but if you're interested in anything that you can see on the screen, you can reach out to me or to Natalie. Plus for the way forward, since I can see that her performance is actually
On a stable side, and...
The scorecard that's on me, I'll work on that plus, but I can see that we're leaning towards to a more stable performance and the partnership that we have, I can see that we're getting better. Would you like to move our weekly meeting to bi-weekly?
Do you say?
I mean, that's okay with me. I mean, and you know, we are on both on teams, so we're on communication that way. So, you know, if I see something that, you know, I'm not afraid to message you and ask. So I think that's completely fine.
Wonderful. I normally change it after 30 days for my clients from weekly to bi-weekly, and then after 30 to 60 days, we can move it to monthly. So that's the process that I'm following. So I'll update you once we can move it to monthly. Of course, that's
Okay.
depending on you if you're okay with it.
Yep, makes sense.
Okay, perfect. That's the end of my slide here, Marco. I appreciate you taking the time, discussing it with me. Do you have anything else to discuss?
No, no, I'm good.
I'm good as well. So you can, you're already aware, you know my email, my team's profile. So if there's anything urgent, please feel free to reach out to me, okay?
Okay, will do, and enjoy your ice cream, okay?
Hi.
Alright, bye.